a new trailer for battlefield one is  coming next week but we've already  gotten a glimpse at what it will contain  I'm Tony and this is your war-torn  gamespot news update ea promised the  trailer would have a quote trainload of  new information considering the  prevalence of trains in world war one  that word choice is definitely a tease  ea will also throw another multiplayer  event at Gamescom next week featuring a  new map with capture points rideable  horses and destructible scenery one of  the events participants tweeted out a  teaser image of the map giving us a  glimpse at its desert setting all in all  you can expect a ton of battlefield 1  info next week battlefield one is coming  to ps4 xbox one and pc on october 21st  expect plenty more map reveals and  trailers between then and now and stay  tuned to gamespot as we bring you all  the latest from gamescom next week for  all the biggest news from the  battlefield you're already in the right  place  you